[Musique]
bonjour B weekend bienvenue en bass
Nandi pour votre émission la voie est
libre c'est un numéro exceptionnel que
nous vous proposons puisque notre invité
n'est autre aujourd'hui que le Cher
bourgeois Bernard casenu le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est avec nous en duplexe
de son bureau place beauovo Paris
bonjour monsieur le ministre bonjour et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vos propos vous le savez sont très
attendus après la publication dans la
presse cette semaine de cette nouvelle
carte des régions 13 régions lieu de 22
actuellement la haute et la basse
enandie vont fusionner on le sait à
partir du 1er janvier 2016 ce qui est
nouveau c'est la presse qui évoque un
arbitrage entre rouan et camp rouan
serait la capitale politique le siège du
Conseil régional et quand serait la
capitale administrative en accueillant
la préfecture de région alors on en
parle dans quelques instants d'abord un
dessin de chunu qui nous a campagne
bonjour Chanu bonjour Franck bonjour
monsieur le ministre Seigneur casne vous
êtes parti guerroyer pour défendre le
royaume et dans votre dos un prince fon
Laurent le haut a soudoyé Laurent le bas
pour faire de nous des serfs au service
d'une capitale une seule capitale rouant
au nom des bas normand je pousse un cri
Arau mon prince on nous fait tort un
commentaire monsieur le ministre sur ces
propos de chonu
justement Chenu est un humoriste et un
caricaturiste donc il peut tout se
permettre mais lorsque je vois des
acteurs politiques reprendre ce type de
discours qui ne correspond rien à la
réalité et qui est une forme de
d'abaissement du débat politique et j'en
suis consterné donc je vais profiter de
cette émission pour remettre les choses
au point alors on va parler de la
Normandie dans dans quelques instants
avant cela on va évoquer ce qui vous a
occupé une grande partie de la semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est cette loi
sur le renseignement vous le savez les
Français se demandent s'ils ne vont pas
être surveillés tous les jours dans leur
geste quotidien euh avec cette cette loi
que leur dites-vous je leur dis des
choses simples d'abord il n'y avait
aucune loi qui régissait le
fonctionnement des services de
renseignement il n'y avait pas de base
juridique depuis la loi de 1991 alors
que les technologies ont évolué alors
que nous sommes confrontés à de
nouvelles menaces qui permettaient
d'encadrer l'activité des services de
renseignement et d'exercer sur ces
services un contrôle h nous nous avons
souhaité après l'affaire Snowden et
c'est à ce moment-là que le principe de
cette loi a été décidé qu'on encadre
l'activité des services de renseignement
c'està-dire que toutes les techniques
soient sur la table qu'on sache
exactement ce que les services de
renseignement sont amenés à faire et que
s'exerce sur eux un contrôle quel est ce
contrôle une autorité administrative
indépendante dont les pouvoirs seront
renforcés un contrôle juridictionnel qui
sera exercé par le Conseil d'État et
pour le cas où les services
interviendraient en contravention avec
la loi pénale par le juge judiciaire et
un contrôle parlementaire qui sera
exercé par la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement qui a désormais un
véritable pouvoir de contrôle sur
l'activité de l'exécutif et des services
on parle d'une boîte noire c'est un
terme qui est souvent
euh utilisé pour chaque français pour
permettre de scanner les données
personnelles et on se dit que si l'on
surf sur des sites euh notamment des
sites jadistes parce que c'est un peu le
but de de cette loi de rechercher les
les terroristes euh que on pourrait se
retrouver avec des enquêteurs au pied de
sa porte simplement pour avoir consulté
quelques sit mais franc beignier vous
êtes journaliste et vous m'interrogz
donc je pense que lorsque vous
développez ce type d'idée vous avez lu
la loi si vous trouvez un article de la
loi qui dis ce que vous venez d'indiquer
euh je je l'amende immédiatement au
Parlement où je me rendrai après notre
émission tout cela n'a pas de sens il y
a deux techniques qui sont réservées
exclusivement à la lutte antiterroriste
euh ce que l'on appelle la détection sur
données anonymes ça ne concerne pas une
surveillance massive des Français c'est
le contraire c'est un dispositif qui ne
conduit qu'à récupérer les données
personnelles de ceux qui peuvent être
engagés dans des activités terroriste et
encore sous contrôle de la Commission
nationale des techniques de
renseignement et sous contrôle du juge
et pour rentrer dans les conversation si
on est convaincu que des terroristes ont
échangé des conversations en vue de la
commission d'un acte terroriste le même
processus est mis en œuvre donc lorsque
j'entends dire ce que vous venez de dire
ce
qui des opposants à cette loi oui mais
les opposants à cette loi soit ils ne
l'ont pas lu quand ils s'expriment je
l'ai constaté pour beaucoup d'entre eux
soit pour ceux qui l'ont lu ils sont
dans un combat idéologique de posture et
politique moi je ne peux pas me
permettre de raisonner ainsi nous avons
été confronté aux attentats de janvier
tous les jours dans ma responsabilité de
ministre de l'Intérieur je vois sur ma
table des formation qui montre
l'importance et l'acqué de la menace et
par conséquent mon rôle c'est de
prévenir le risque de commission
d'attentat terroriste et c'est de le
faire dans le respect rigoureux des
libertés publiques et cette loi c'est
une loi qui a été élaborée pour encadrer
l'activité des services de renseignement
et pas pour surveiller l'ensemble des
Français c'est pas une surveill non
seulement c'est mais mais non seulement
il n'y a pas de surveillance de masse
des Français mais cette loi l'interdit
HM puisque les techniques qui sont les
techniques réservées à la lutte contre
le terrorisme ne concernent que la lutte
contre le terrorisme et ne peuvent être
mobilisés que dans le cadre de la mise
en œuvre de processus de contrôle qui
jusqu'à présent n'existait pas donc
c'est une loi qui a été conçue pour
encadrer encore une fois l'activité des
services de renseignement et permettre
de de lutter contre le terrorisme en
réservant un certain nombre de
techniques à la lutte contre le au
terrorisme et en encadrant ces technique
c'est donc une loi et c'est la première
fois depuis 1991 que l'on intègre les
évolutions technologique dans une loi et
compose clairement le principe d'un
contrôle maximal sur l'activité des
services de renseignement
a sur pardonnez-moi Franck bélier aussi
faudrait-il sur des sujets de ce type et
je conclus sur ce point parce que c'est
important qu'alors que la menace est
grave que nous devons être conscients de
cela et dire la vérité aux Français on
puisse sur des sujets de cette nature
est dans la rigueur intellectuelle et
l'exigence de vérité très bien alors on
va évoquer à présent un autre sujet qui
passionne les Normands euh on le voit à
travers les échanges sur Internet euh
euh c'est la question de la fusion des
deux Normandies et du choix de la
capitale le 1er janvier prochain il n'y
aura plus que 13 régions en France au
lieu de 22 actuellement euh il y aura
surtout une seule Normandie et je le
disais au début de cette émission on a
découvert cette semaine cette carte dans
la presse avec Ran qui deviendrait la
capitale politique et le siège du
Conseil régional et quand qui serait
choisi comme préfecture avant de vous
laisser la parole c'est intéressant de
vous entendre parce que c'est la
première fois que vous allez vous
exprimer sur le sujet on va écouter
Laurent Fabius etia quelques semaines
sur notre antenne c'est très court
écoutez
bien a cette idée qui peut avoir de de
la force mais je tiens essentiellement
et Bernard casenu aussi nous en avons
discuté à ce que il y ait un bon
équilibre et que ce soit positif pour
nos conitoyen voilà Laurent Fabius qui
plaide pour un bon équilibre entre rouan
et qui dit très clairement que quand
doit être la préfecture et Ran la
capitale politique le siège du Conseil
régional qu'est-ce que vous dites ce
midi mais est-ce que vous avez vu une
déclaration de Laurent fabus qui dit
cela Laurent fabus s'est prononcé je
viens de l'entendre sur votre antenne
pour un équilibre entre les deux villes
et pour un équilibre aussi d'ailleurs
entre l'ensemble des villes qui
contribuent au dynamisme de la Normandie
mais la déclaration que vous venez de
faire concernant la préfecture ici la
région là n'a pas été faite par
leenfabus davantage que par moi donc
pourquoi encore une fois prêter à
Laurent fabus des propos qu' n'a pas
tenu alimenter des polémiques qui n'ont
pas lieu d'être et à baisser le débat
politique ce qui n'est pas la le
meilleur serviceur SC quel est la
réalité non mais non mais Franck bniier
ce sont des sujets sérieux vous venez de
me poser une question en prêtant à
Laurent fabus des déclarations qu'il n'a
pas fait tout cela je le constate
d'ailleurs en silence alimente des
chroniques de presse d'une médiocrité
absolue alimente des propos politiques
polémique et qui sont nature à diviser
tout le monde là où nous avons fait la
Normandie pour rassembler toutes les
énergies donc faisons une mise au point
parce que comme c'est moi qui porté
cette loi comme c'est moi qui a porté
cette loi à l'Assemblée nationale comme
c'est la gauche il faut quand même le
rappeler à la droite qui est dans le
commentaire mais qui n'a pas été
beaucoup dans l'action au cours des
dernières décennies c'est la gauche qui
a rassemblé la Normandie et c'est votre
serviteur qui va présenter en conseil
des ministres mercredi prochain un
dispositif qui va permettre dans toutes
les régions de France pas pas simplement
la Normandie de d'adapter
l'administration territoriale de l'État
à ce nouveau contexte de la création de
13 région alors quel dispositif
justement venons-en au dossier normand
si vous voulez bien quel dispositif
qu'allez-vous proposer en conseil des
ministres la semaine prochaine et
d'abord je ne vais pas proposer Franck
beignier sortez de
votre de de votre studio régional pour
regarder le problème global je vais pas
présenter un dispositif pour la
Normandie j'ai présenter un dispositif
pour le pays tout entier par nous sommes
dans nous sommes dans une république une
indivisible et le principe d'égalité
devant la loi c'est un principe général
du droit auquel il faut se conformer
absolument donc qu'est-ce que je vais
quels sont les principes qui vont être
annoncés mercredi qui l'ont d'ailleurs
déjà été par le Premier ministre et par
moi-même nous devons adapter
l'administration territoriale de l'État
sur tous les territoires en fonction de
la création des 13 régions c'est ce que
nous allons faire comment est-ce que
nous allons le faire nous allons
désigner des préfets préfigurateurs dans
chaque nouvelle région et des directeurs
d'administration centrale pour les
grandes administrations le rectorat
l'ARS les directions économiques de
manière à ce que les préfets c'estes
directeurs préfigurateurs organisent en
concertation étroite avec les présidents
de région avec les maires des grandes
villes avec les présidents des
départements une administration
territoriale sur le territoire de la
nouvelle région qui soit équilibré et le
débat tel qu'il est en train de se poser
est un mauvais débat parce que ce n'est
pas c contre rouan je dirais même que
c'est la Normandie d'abord et par
conséquent c'est rouan et C ensemble
pour faire en sorte que la Normandie se
développe et qu'elle ait toutes ses
chances donc ce que je vais confier
comme mission au préfet préfigurateur
c'est d'aller à la rencontre des élus
c'est de mobiliser les deux présidents
de région et les présidents de
départements et des grandes villes qui
ont un rôle à jouer pour faire en sorte
qu'ensemble nous construisions dans
l'unité de la Normandie puisque c'est ce
que j'ai voulu en portant cette loi avec
Laurent Fabius que nous puissions créer
les conditions du meilleur équilibre
plutôt que d'être dans la division les
guerres de
clocher les les les polémiques qui n'ont
pas lieu d'être j'appelle tous les
Normands quel que soit leur sensibilité
politique même s'il m'a pas échappé
qu'il y aura des élections régionales
qui peuvent aiguiser certains appec
alimenter certaines démagogies à se
rassembler parce que toute ma vie
politique dans la Normandie ça a été le
rassemblement de toutes les forces pour
la
Normandie de débats qui sont là pour
diviser et abaisser si si vous me
permettez malgré tout le débat existe et
il a été lancé par certains élus députés
notamment on va écouter ça dure très peu
de temps mais Hervé main qui est
susceptible de mener la liste pour la
droite UMP udi modem et lui il a en fait
une proposition et je vous propose de
l'écouter c'est de mettre la capitale à
cor et la préfecture à rouan et on
réagit juste derrière
bien pour la Normandie il faut penser
notre organisation autrement et
l'organisation que nous voulons c'est
une organisation où on crée les
conditions d'un réseau dont tout le
monde va profiter et donc l'idée c'est
la préfecture bien entendu sera dans la
plus grande ville c'està-dire à rouan le
conseil régional le lieu du pouvoir et
de l'investissement à ca parce que c est
mieux desservi plus central en
Normandie plus accessible tout
simplement et puis au Havre les
structures dédiées au développement
économique alors est-ce que Hervé Morin
a tort quand il s'avance justement sur
l'emplacement de la préfecture et de la
capitale de région c'est pas un débat
actuel deux remarques non mais deux
remarques sur ce que vient de dire Hervé
Morin d'abord il exprime des idées le
préfet prévigurateur aura pour rôle de
les réueillir comme celle de tous les
autres deuxième remarque Hervé Morin a
été pendant longtemps dans la majorité
il n'a absolument rien réussi à obtenir
pour faire la Normandie qui l'appelit de
ses vœux nous nous
avons été élus en 2012 et en 2014 elle
est faite et par contre et c'est comme
ça d'ailleurs sur beaucoup de sujets
avec Hervé Morin il a été ministre de la
Défense il n'a rien fait pour encadrer
l'activité des services de renseignement
nous le faisons et maintenant il est
dans la surenchère moi je considère que
la politique c'est pas un exercice de
démagogie ce n'est pas un exercice qui
consiste selon les circonstances à
changer de position
et dit des choses intéressantes le
préfet préfigurateur les prendra en
compte comme cell de tous les autres
élus et nous avancerons ensemble ce que
je vois simplement parce que je lis bien
entendu avec beaucoup d'attention la
presse c'est que la droite qui n'a pas
réussi alors qu'elle a été en situation
de responsabilité pendant des années à
faire cette cette grande Normandie alors
qu'elle en parlait beaucoup est
aujourd'hui dans un exercice qui
consiste parce qu'il y a des élections à
créer sur tous les sujets de la division
et de la polémique et moi moi je ne
seraai pas candidat à ces élections je
ne serai même plus du tout candidat à
des élections en bassnormandie donc j'ai
une distance qui me permet de regarder
ce qu'est l'intérêt du territoire
personn le rassemblement vous connaissez
bien la bastandie vous êtes arrivé à
Cherbourg il y a plus de 20 ans c'est en
1994 vous avz posé vos valises dans le N
Cotentin on pour en parler tout à
l'heure à la fin de l'émission mais à
titre personnel Bernard casenu je
m'adresse non pas au ministre de
l'intérieur mais au banormand que vous
êtes votre choix personnel quel
serait-il s'il fallait déterminer un
lieu pour cette capitale régionale
personnellement mais mais je ne vais pas
vous répondre à cette question parce que
le mon choix personnel tout le monde
s'en moque et je n'imagine pas moi que
la politique tourne autour de mon
nombril ce que j'estime c'est qu'il est
de mon rôle comme ministre de
l'Intérieur de créer et avec Laurent
fabus avec lequel nous avons une
rolution depuis 30 ans qui est une
relation de confiance d'amitié et
d'estime il est de not notre rôle
notamment à tous les deux qui sommes au
gouvernement mais aussi des présidents
de région mais aussi des maires des
grandes villes de faire en sorte que
nous puissions créer les conditions
d'une unité et d'une force c'est pour
cela que nous avons fait cette grande
région et lorsque je vois que quelques
mois après que nous avons réussi à faire
voter ce grand projet au Parlement il y
a tout un ensemble d'acteurs qui abaisse
le débat politique en essayant de créer
surtout les conditions de la division je
me dis que si nous ne sommes pas là pour
veiller à ce que l'intérêt général
l'emporte et ils finiront par affaiblir
la Normandie de leur appétit de pouvoir
quel est la procédure justement àelel
Laurent Fabius ni moi à quel moment
allez-vous annoncer le choix de la
capitale ou du chef-lieu provisoire
puisque c'est le terme employé par la
loi mais contrairement à ce que j'ai lu
dans la presse tout ce que j'ai lu dans
la presse je vous le dis vous en aurez
la vérification dans quelques jours est
totalement faux et et nous annoncerons
les chef-lieux au début du mois de
juillet après que les préfets
préfigurateurs auront conduit cette
concertation donc lorsque j'entends dire
que des choix ont été faits c'est faux
lorsque j'entends dire que nous allons
annoncer les préfectures les capitales
régionales mercredi c'est faux lorsque
j'entends dire que Laurent fabus ou moi
dans une espèce de querelle territoriale
aurions essayé de faire prévaloir les
intérêts de telle ville plutôt que telle
autre c'est faux parce que nous
travaillons ensemble de façon excellente
sur ce sujet pour des raisons qui
tiennent au lien de la confiance et au
lien de l'amitié donc j'appelle tous
ceux qui écrivent et qui parlent arrêtez
de dire des choses fausse qui divise et
qui inquiète l'opinion publique pour ne
s'en tenir que ce qu'à ce qu'est la
vérité d'une démarche qui est là pour
assurer l'unité et donner de la force à
la Normandie et moi je ne dérogerai pas
de ce chemin donc on a compris que
c'était pas avant le le mois de juillet
votre décision salad je pense que vous
avez compris aussi qu'il faut arrêter
sur ce sujet de raconter absolument
n'importe quoi en terr pour vous posez
les questions par rapport à tout ce qui
est paru cette semaine dans la presse
notamment cette carte qui a été publié
et largement diffusé dans les médias
malgré tout je disais le débat existe
certains élus de la Manche votre
département comme Philippe B nouveau
président du du conseil départemental
disait il faut pas que la Normandie
tende trop vers l'Est se rapproche trop
de Paris est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous pourriez
partager mais c'est un raisonnement que
je ne partage pas et qui est d'ailleurs
très contradictoire de ce qu'a voulu
faire la droite lorsqu'elle était en
situation de responsabilité et autant
j'ai pu m'opposer à certains certaines
orientations de la politique du
précédent gouvernement autant j'ai
toujours considéré que l'idée de faire
de la Normandie la façade maritime de la
région parisienne dans le cadre d'une
grande vision d'aménagement du
territoire était intéressante et par
conséquent il faut que la
Normandie ramène Paris à elle nous y
avons intérêt économiquement et qu'en
même temps elle soit capable de de
regarder le Grand Large parce que c'est
dans euh la capacité qu'elle aura
embrasser les enjeux maritimes
portuaires que elle pourra aussi trouver
la force de son développement donc il
faut être ce trait d'union entre la
région parisienne et la mer de de la
Manche alors on va refermer ce chapitre
Normandie et on attendra de connaître
vos révélations et vos annonces début
juillet on l'a bien compris vous revenez
régulièrement hein dans la Manche et
dans votre ville de Cherbourg il y a 15
jours ça ne vous a pas échappé le
département a changé de président euh on
disait Philippe Bas remplacé
Jean-François lerand avec lequel vous
avez beaucoup travaillé notamment sur
les énergies marines renouvelables euh
votre commentaire sur ce passage de
témoins dans un département que vous
connaissez
bien vous savez moi je suis très
désireux de travailler avec euh les élus
de toute sensibilité parce que je pense
que notre territoire a besoin encore une
fois de force d'unité de rassemblement
et lorsque j'étais dans le département
de la Manche même si nous sommes parfois
opposés avec Jean-François leand à force
de travailler ensemble sur des projets
nous avons fini par nouer des relations
de confiance et des relations d'amitié
et nous avons porté beaucoup de dossiers
ensemble et j'ai trouvé que c'était très
bien ainsi et moi je n'ai pas
l'intention avec Philippe Bas de jouer
sur l'éclivage politique traditionnel
les petites divisions et je ferai en
sorte d'être au service du département
de la Manche comme je l'ai été à
l'époque de Jean-François lerand j'ai
d'ailleurs de très bonnes personnel avec
Philippe bar alors on va parler
justement du département de de la Manche
vous revenez régulièrement à Cherbourg
je le disais il y a quelques semaines la
direction d'Areva annoncé la suppression
de 500 postes à l'usine de retraitement
de déchets de la Hague dans les 5 ans
qui
viennent l'État et actionnaire de
d'Areva est-ce qu'il est possible que
l'État fasse blocage à ce plan social
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourrait
envisager mais l'État est là pour
construire une stratégie industriel là
où il est actionnaire qui permett de
garantir au maximum l'emploi c'est dans
cet esprit-là que nous avons reçu les
organisation syndicale avec Emmanuel
Macron à berc il y a de cela quelques
semaines pour leur dire que au regard de
cet objectif l'état prendrait toutes ses
responsabilités et Emmanuel Macron
conduit des discussions avec les acteurs
du nucléaire notamment la direction
d'Areva pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions redresser cette entreprise
parce que quelle est la situation à
laquel ce gouvernement est confronté il
faut aussi le le dire très clairement il
y a eu des choix d'investissement qui
ont considérablement affaibli
l'entreprise je pense notamment aux
choix qui ont été faits en matière
d'investissement miniier deuxièmement il
y a une stratégie entre les acteurs du
nucléaire qui n'a pas été cohérente et
concertée et qui n a pas conduit ces
acteurs à être performants à l'export et
on l'a vu sur le choix des réacteurs à
promouvoir l'exportation et bien le
gouvernement veut avoir une véritable
stratégie industrielle et il récupère
aujourd'hui une entreprise qui a été
affaiblie par ses choix hasardeux par
ses aterboims et qu'il faut redresser
bien l'état prendra ses responsabilités
et comme l'a dit le Premier ministre en
réponse à une question gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron nous le ferons avec un
objectif une filière nucléaire forte qui
sauvegarde les emplois donc on ne sort
pas du nucléaire c'est la question que
je voulais vous poser on ne prépare pas
la sortie du du nucléair mais c mais ce
débat il est il existe revient il est
récurrent depuis 1991 que je suis élu de
la région de Cherbourg non seulement ce
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
sortir du nucléaire mais il a
l'intention de moderniser la filière
électronucléaire de lui donner plus de
force en mettant fin à des choix
stratégiques et a des atermoim qui n'ont
que trop duré qui ont affaibli les
grandes industries et de le faire dans
le cadre d'une stratégie industrielle
qui est une visibilité une libilité et
qui permettent aux acteurs du nucléaire
notamment au DF Areva de travailler
davantage en ble on avait fait campagne
en 2012 à droite pour expliquer que si
nous arrivions en situation de
responsabilité il n'y aurait plus
d'emploi dans le nucléire et on se rend
compte que c'est faux et que non
seulement c'est faux mais que nous
sommes en train de corriger des choix
hasardeux qui ont été faits à une autre
époque alors vous suivez
particulièrement ce qui se passe en
bastanandie notamment aux abattoirs aim
de la Manche un plan de reprise a été
accepté par le tribunal de commerce de
Coutance on va rappeler ce qui s'est
passé il y a quelques jours 206 emplois
vont être sauvés euh sur le site de
Sainte-Cécile près de villeedieu mais
150 vont être supprimés l'État va prêter
2 millions et demi d'euros euh à une
scope c'est une société coopérative
ouvrière donc une société gérée par les
salariés l'État avait un engagement
quelque part vis-à-vis de ses
abattoir écoutez moi j'ai été sollicité
sur ces abattoirs par euh le président
du conseil général de l'époque et
Laurent bvet enfin par JeanFrançois
lerand et Laurent bovvet lorsque j'étais
ministre du Budget j'ai pris à l'époque
mes responsabilités
en permettant à l'entreprise de
poursuivre son activité en lui apportant
le concours de l'État qui pouvait lui
être apporté et si ces emplois ont été
maintenus à l'époque c'est parce que
j'ai pris cette
responsabilité des nouveaux événements
sont survenus qui mettaient l'entreprise
en
situation extrêmement difficile elle
risquait de disparaître j'ai de nouveau
en lien avec les organisations
syndicales leurs représentants le préfet
les élus
mis en fait en sorte que nous puissions
apporter un nouveau concours pour que
l'activité puisse se poursuivre et par
conséquent nous avons toujours été au
côté de cette entreprise qui représente
plusieurs centaines d'emplois dans le
département parce que encore une fois
l'emploi c'est l'objectif c'est la
priorité c'est ce pourquoi nous nous
battons alors autre
dossier sur lequel on on a fait beaucoup
de sujets ces derniers jours c'est celui
de l'hôpital de cherbour en février
dernier l'inspection je rappelle aussi
les fait l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales a rendu un rapport qui
préconise le départ de 187 personnes
l'hôpital accuse un déficit de 40
millions d'euros est-ce que selon vous
vous connaissez bien cet hôpital pour
avoir été maire de Cherbourg pendant
plusieurs années est-ce que cet hôpital
a un avenir ou est-ce qu'il est en
danger on peut se poser la question mais
non seulement cet hôpital un avenir mais
il est absolument indispensable pour le
bassin- Deville de cherrebourg l'hôpital
public c'est l'hôpital auquel ont accès
tous les citoyens et qui permet pour
tous les citoyens de dispenser les soins
que la République doit à ceux et
notamment parmi les plus modestes qui
sont confrontés à la maladie c'est la
raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
dans d'autres période le gouvernement a
apporté un soutien financier à cet
hôpital depuis
2012li résorber ce déficit de 40
millions d'euros mais il faudra faire
des efforts d'organisation ces efforts
d'organisation ne pe peuvent pas se
faire sans concertation avec les
organisations syndicales il faut de la
concertation de la part de ceux qui
doivent prendre les décisions et de la
responsabilité de la part des
organisations syndicales et tout cela
n'est possible que dans la dynamique du
dialogue il faut que l'État soit capable
aussi à un moment donné de prendre des
décisions c'est la raison pour laquelle
par exemple moi je me suis opposé bec et
ongle à au déclassement dont on parlait
là aussi par VO de presse sur la
maternité et que les choses ont été
clarifiées par un engagement très Clairé
de la ministre de la Santé Marie
soltouren et je l'en remercie après que
des démarches ont été effectuées par
jeanev goselin et par moi-même auprès
d'elle de façon très puissante oui la
maternité qui va rester donc ni en
niveau 3 qui va permettre de deerver un
certain nombre de personnel oui et sur
ce sujet de l'hôpital on constate que
moi je ne fais pas comme sur la grande
Normandie comme sur tous les autres
sujets des déclarations tous les jours
j'interviens peu mais en revanche chaque
jour
j'agis alors vous agissez pour cherbour
et vous aimez cherbour vous aviez dit il
y a quelques temps sur cette antenne que
vous aviez un lien vicéral avec le Nord
Cotentin alors on va voir une image si
vous voulez bien à la folie oui on va
voir une image c'est il y a quelques
jours au cours de cette campagne des
départementales le public qui vous
acclame il y avait à peu près 450
personnes au cours de cet entre de tour
des des élections qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait justement de voir ces chers
bourgeois même si vous êtes parti euh
euh sur Paris avec d'autres occupations
d'autres responsabilités mais vous
accueillir à bras ouvert mais d'abord je
ne suis pas parti mon cœur est à
Cherbourg tout le temps et si je je peux
à votre antenne dire précisément tout ce
qui est fait sur chacun des dossiers
c'est parce que il ne s'écoule pas une
journée sans que je consacre mon temps à
cette ville il y a à mon cabinet
d'ailleurs une personne qui suit
particulièrement ces sujets normand et
chers bourgeois à mes côtés et euh
cherbour c'est ma vie c'est la ville où
est né mon fils c'est là que j'ai fait
mes premières armes en politique c'est
là où j'ai mes amis et c'est là aussi
désormais où j'ai de la nostalgie parce
que les paysages les lumières les chers
bourgeois les projets tout ça me manque
terriblement c'est là que vous venezir
vous ressourcez quelque part par rapport
à ces occupations nationales et même
internationales mais c'est c'est là où
je viens me ressourcer je disais à ma
famille R
que la charge parlementaire liée à
l'actualité depuis le mois de janvier
notamment la charge tout court qui
m'empêche de venir aussi souvent que je
le souhaiterais fait que je ressens
profondément un grand manque je vais
venir le compenser au printemps en
venant me promener sur les plages du
côentin quand on a été ministre du
Budget des affaires européennes de
l'Intérieur aujourd'hui c'est quoi
l'avenir que quels sont les les projets
quand on arrivé à ce niveau-là parti de
cherbour je le rappelle en 94
écoutez le projet c'est de bien faire ce
que j'ai à faire de façon rigoureuse et
sans me
disperser de le faire aussi en ayant
toujours à chaque instant une pensée
pour la Normandie et pour cherbour et
pour la suite vous savez moi je je vous
redis ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
dire à plusieurs reprises il y a deux
catégories d'hommes politique ceux qui
s'estiment indispensable et ceux qui
pensaient être pouvoir être utile à un
moment ben j' apptient à la deuxème
catégorie et on verra bien ce que
l'avenir réserve on ne sait jamais
quelle sera sera le chemin qu'on sera
amené à je n'ai pas de projet non aucun
et mon seul objectif c'est de bien faire
ce que j'ai à faire aujourd'hui et bien
on termina par ça vous savez quand on
met beaucoup d'énergie quand on met
beaucoup d'énergie à essayer de bien
faire ce que l'on a à faire on n'est pas
toujours sûr d'y parvenir donc il faut
rester concentrer voilà et on vous
revoit très prochainement en Normandie
chez vous du côté de Cherbourg merci à
vous merci Bernard cas d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et d'avoir accepté cet
entretien d'une demi-heure dans dans la
voie libre merci CHU de nous avoir
accompagné et on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour une deuxième
partie avec le maire de camp Joë Bruno à
tout à
[Musique]
l'heure
retour dans votre émission La voyz Libre
vous l'avez entendu il y a quelques
minutes dans la première partie de
l'émission le ministre de l'Intérieur
Bernard casenov s'est exprimé sur la
réforme territoriale et la réunification
de la Normandie également sur le choix
de la capitale normande on reçoit sur ce
plateau le maire um de camp Joël Bruno
pour réagir à ses propos bonjour bonjour
CHU est avec nous pour un nouveau dessin
bonjour chudur bonjour Oui Fran on a un
peu l'impression que les gens de la
Haute Normandie et Laurent Fabius ma
Rossignol tire la couverture à eux et
puis après ils vont passer dans la phase
lesedredon pour étouffer un petit peu
les protestations des banormand alors on
va écouter justement un banormand et le
maire de C Joel Bruno dans un instant
mais on va revenir sur ce que disait
Bernard CASNAV il y a quelques minutes à
propos du choix de la capitale de la
Normandie pour lui rien n'est fait et
les informations que l'on a pu lire dans
la presse et bien sont erronés on
l'écoute ce que je vois simplement parce
que je lis bien entendu avec beaucoup
d'attention la presse c'est que la
droite qui n'a pas réussi alors qu'elle
a été en situation de responsabilité
pendant des années à faire cette cette
grande Normandie alors qu'elle en
parlait beaucoup est aujourd'hui dans un
exercice qui consiste parce qu'il y a
des élections à créer sur tous les
sujets de la division et de la polémique
nous annoncerons les chef-lieux au début
du mois de juillet après que les préfets
préfigurateurs auront conduit cette
concertation donc lorsque j'entends dire
que des choix ont été fait c'est faux
lorsque j'entends dire que nous allons
annoncer les préfectures les capitales
régionales mercredi c'est faux lorsque
j'entends dire que Laurent fabus ou moi
dans une espèce de querelle territoriale
auons essayé de faire prévaloir les
intérêts de telle ville plutôt que tel
autre c'est faux parce que nous
travaillons ensemble de façon excellente
sur ce sujet pour des raisons qui
tiennent au lien de la confiance et au
lien de l'amitié donc j'appelle tous
ceux qui écrivent et qui parlent arrêter
de dire des choses fausses qui divisent
et qui inquiète l'opinion publique pour
ne s'en tenir que ce qu'à ce qu'est la
vérité d'une démarche qui est là pour
assurer l'unité et donner de la force à
la Normandie et moi je ne dérogerai pas
de ce chemin voilà les médias qui en
début de semaine je vous le rappelle
évoquent un conseil régional à rouan et
une préfecture à Camp tout est faux
selon le ministre rien n'est joué la
décision sera rendue officiellement le
1er juillet enfin tout début juillet
votre commentaire Joel Bruno justement
je crois qu' il y a au moins un point
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
Bernard casenuve enfin un point d'accord
entre nous c'est que c'est pas un sujet
politique au sens politicien du terme la
vraie question c'est de savoir comment
demain on organise la Normandie pour que
ce soit une région puissante une région
qui possède une vraie dynamique
intrinsèque et qui soit capable d'offrir
des perspectives à celles et ceux qui
vivent c'est ça le vrai sujet mais
est-ce qu'il y a une gauche qui défend
en r et une droite qui défend quand on
on a il évidment il y a évidemment il y
a évidemment des positionnements
personnels euh et je pense que en
relisant Bernard k faisait allusion aux
déclarations des uns et des autres il me
semble que le maire de camp a toujours
eu la même position à savoir euh
peut-être d'ailleurs que certains
peuvent me reprocher de pas avoir été
suffisamment véhément parce que j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il fallait pour avoir
du poids dans ces positions amener de la
cohérence et de l'argumentation mon
argumentation elle a toujours été très
simple c'est que si on veut réussir la
Normandie et si on veut pas que la
Normandie soit simplement une fausse
région qui serait d'un côté aspiré par
par le Grand Paris qui va naturellement
jusqu'à la scinene et de l'autre aspiré
aussi par l'axe reen nante si on veut
une Normandie puissante il faut une
Normandie équilibrée et qui soit pas
évidemment concentré sur donc il faut
effectivement une répartition des rô
entre les grand agoms élus rouanais qui
veulent que le Conseil régional soit
plutôt à rouan et la préfecture à qu
vous dites l'inverse c'est ça non mais
on est on n'est pas sur un débat de
savoir de savoir entre les maires sa
ritépartir qui prend quoi euh
c'est l'objet alors il y a effectivement
deux phases le ministre de l'Intérieur
vient de le rappeler il y a d'abord une
phase administrative gouvernementale au
au f au cours de laquelle un préfet
préfigurateur va déterminer le lieu
qu'il préconise comme
préfecture ce lieu de et c'est à l'État
bien évidemment de déterminer où il met
la préfecture de région après il y a une
deuxième phase il y a une deuxième phase
excusez-moi je vous interrompe une
deuxième phase qui est celle de savoir
où on met le conseil régional et là
cette décision là elle appartient à la
Major é issu des prochaines élections
régionales et ce que vous dites c'est
que le meilleur endroit pour mettre le
conseil régional c'est quand oui et je
le dis pas par préférentialisme local je
le dis là aussi en argumentant je dis
que il est assez naturel que la
préfecture de région soit dans la ville
la plus peuplée la plus importante donc
l'agglomération
roanaise en plus entre nous la proximité
de Paris fera plaisir à un certain
nombre de haut fonctionnaires et puis il
est en revanche et j' j'explique
pourquoi il me paraît intéressant
d'avoir le conseil régional à camp pour
des raisons de proximité avec les
citoyens cette cette Normandie il faut
la il faut la construire de façon à ce
qu'elle soit proche des citoyens et si
on veut qu'elle soit proche
effectivement quand un lieu central qui
permet de répondre à cet impératif là
les préfectures départementales elles
faisant de l'autre côté pour l'action
gouvernementale l'action de l'État
effectivement assurant la proximité des
citoyens dans chacun des départements
alors nous sommes à 8 mois des élections
régionales et on voit bien la campagne a
déjà commencé sur le terrain Hervé Morin
qui brigue la tête d'une liste UMP udi
MoDem était dans la Manche jeudi dernier
on l'a vu à quelques reprises d'ailleurs
dans la région là depuis quelques
semaines vous êtes maire de camp mais
aussi président de l'UMP dans le
Calvados les républicains maintenant on
pourra peut-être en parler dans quelques
instants est-ce que vous pensez comme
Bruno Le Maire qu'il est le meilleur
candidat Hervé min pour mener cette
liste de la droite clairement ce que je
pense c'est qu'il faut une liste d'union
ent entre le centre et l'UMP pour
briguer enfin pour répondre à à la ce
qui est l'essentiel c'est-à-dire porter
un projet pour la Normandie toute
entière demain et c'est donc estand
Hervé Morin est un très bon candidat il
pourrait y en avoir d'autres mais chacun
sait c'est je veux dire je je j'enfonce
une porte ouverte en disant ça qu'il y
aura des accords nationaux entre l'UMP
et l'UDI que l'UDI aura certaines tête
de liste et c'est vrai que il est
vraisemblable que la Normandie ait une
tête de liste udi donc en l'occurrencev
Morin et bien évidemment dès lors que
les choses seront actées dès lors que
les choses seront actées je serai
évidemment derrière celui ou celle en
l'occurrence si servve Morin je serai
évidemment derrière celui qui portera le
projet porté par ma famille politique
alors vous êtes maire de C depuis un peu
plus d'un an vous connaissez également
bien la région puisque vous avez été un
des bras droits de René garek jusqu'en
2004 récemment j'ai été conseiller
régional quand même et conseiller
régional chef de l'opposition mais vous
avez connaissez bien c'est ce que je
disais les affaires régionales est-ce
que si votre famille politique vous le
demande vous pourriez participer à ces
élections régionales euh non non même si
on me le demandait je répondrai non
parce que j'ai pris l'engagement auprès
des canises et des canis de me consacrer
à à temps plein à ce mandat avec dans
dans le prolongement naturel la
présidence de la communauté
d'agglomération et croyez-moi c'est
vraiment un un travail à temps plein ce
qui veut pas dire que évidemment je
porte pas un œil extrêmement attentif à
ce qui va se passer dans le cadre des
élections régionales alors le mardi 28
avril à 20h au Mémorial de camp vous ne
serez pas candidat on l'a bien compris
au au régional en revanche vous
participez d'une certaine façon à la
promotion de la ville de camp et le 28
avril au Mémorial et bien il y a ce
grand colloque intitulé cand cause
normand on va y retrouver des
personnalités comme Xavier gravelen le
manager du stad Maral de camp le
philosophe Michel hfry un coloque qui
sera animé par Henri sagier qui était
rédacteur en chef ici à à France 3 camp
l'objectif en fait c'est de défendre
camp c'est ça dans cette grande
Normandie l'objectif c'est de démontrer
que quand et et les territoires qui
l'entourent parce que quand c'est
l'ouest de la Normandie avec les
territoires qui l'entourent les réseaux
de ville moyennes en allant jusqu'à
cherrebourg bien sûr euh c'est
l'objectif de cette soirée qui est pas
vraiment un colloc hein c'est c'est une
soirée plutôt entre guillemets festive
mais pour montrer que nous avons sur
notre territoire un certain nombre
d'excellence un certain nombre de de
qualités que nous devons enfin qui qui
sont absolument nécessaires à la
Normandie et la Normandie encore une
fois elle doit se construire de manière
équilibrée entre les différentes
territoire entre C et roin bien sûr mais
aussi en intégrant le Havre et les
réseaux de ville moyenne parce que nous
avons besoin tous ensemble de faire
réussir la Normandie c'est ça le sujet
c'est ouvert c'est ouvert au grand
public et et justement c'est l'objectif
c'est aussi que dans dans une région où
on a plutôt tendance à à faire preuve
parfois d'une modestie un peu
exagérée sans que que nous soyons tous
ensemble bien conscient que nous avons
un certain nombre de de richesse et de
qualité et qu'il faut oser le dire de
temps en temps alors on reparlera de
cette campagne des régionales d'ici le
mois de décembre les dates sont
officielles c'est le 6 et le 13 décembre
1er second tour j'aimerais que l'on dise
un mot sur ce changement de nom de de
l'UMP qui s'appelle plus l'UMP désormais
les républicains vous étiez favorable
bon je pense que ça fera l'objet de la
nous avons effectivement un congrès
national le 30 mai euh les républicains
oui de toute façon nous sommes
effectivement avant tout des
républicains mais encore une une fois le
vrai sujet derrière le changement de nom
c'est surtout la capacité à présenter au
aux Français et ça devient absolument
impératif un projet alternatif crédible
et sérieux pour sortir la France de
l'ornière dans laquelle dans laquelle
elle est aujourd'hui le vrai projet plus
que le nom plus que le nom c'est le
projet qui est derrière qui est
important certains disent on change les
nom on ch le nom mais on change pas les
hommes non mais je dire il y a plein
d'hommes et de femmes de femmes et
d'hommes au sein de l'UMP des gens de
talent et qui justement ont capacité à
appter un projet important et euh et et
mobilisateur pour la prochaine grande
esséance qui sera l'élection
présidentielle mais objectivement
j'appartiens à un mouvement qui a encore
besoin de beaucoup travailler pour
justement incarner cette alternance
absolument indispensable euh pour 2017
alors 2017 justement c'est pratiquement
demain ça sera certainement lancé après
cette campagne des régionales vous avez
déjà un préféré pour la course à la
présidence
ouis il faut il faut déjà attendre que
tous les candidats potentiels
s'expriment euh je ferai évidemment en
temps utiles connaître ma préférence qui
n'engagera que moi d'ailleurs mais euh
on aura de toute façon toute une
organisation autour d'une primaire
citoyenne euh pour reprendre une
expression qui a déjà été utilisée qui
permettra à chacun de se positionner et
de faire émerger le mieux placé ou la
mieux placé pour porter eu projet que
dit non il est pas officiellement fait
en tout cas pas officiellement voilà
officieusement oui vous vous pouvez en
tirer les conclusions que vous souhaitez
euh on le dira pas donc on l'a compris
ce midi merci jel Bruno d'
à no questions ce midi merci CHU avec un
dernier dessin que l'on découvre oui on
frit Bruno c'est les républicains et
fabus c'est le roi c'est moi voilà et
bien on terminera par c'est un
caricaturiste qui parle et n'oubliez pas
donc ce grand coloc cand cause normand
le 28 avril à 20h au Mémorial de camp
merci à tous les deux bon weekend la
semaine prochaine nous parlerons
tourisme dans la voye
librere
[Musique]